keiner schaut euch das mal an das sind
glaube ich alles flaschen wo kein pfand
drauf ist oder wenn sie einmal laufen
sonst aufhören
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ich
fange man hier auf dem bett an wir haben
auch schon etwas später ich war gerade
joggen kurzen applaus vielleicht dafür
und müsste bei einer idee gekommen
ich habe auf jeden fall irgendwann mal
relativ viele amerikanische videos
gesehen wo halt menschen versucht haben
mit möglichst wenig geld möglichst lange
auszukommen das ganze ist schon nach
deutschland übergeschwappt also ich hab
das jetzt auch schon der ein oder andere
youtuber gemacht deswegen dass jetzt
auch noch zu machen finde ich irgendwie
doof mir ist dann allerdings die idee
gekommen dass ich jetzt auch noch
schlafen gehe vielleicht müde
nein welche nicht schlaf auf jeden fall
ist mir die idee gekommen wie sieht das
ganze dann aus wenn man versucht mit gar
keinem geld auszukommen ich habe mir
gedacht ich fang ist ein blog jetzt
einfach mal an ich wollte erstmal ein
bisschen raus gehen ich nehme euch mit
und wir versuchen
ich würde einfach mal sagen für die
nächsten 24 stunden vielleicht kriege
ich auch irgendwie ansonsten haarschnitt
auf jeden fall ist das ziel einfach
umsonst zu leben ich will gar nicht lang
lagern und würde sagen ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß mit dem video ich hoffe
natürlich erst mit cool das kann man
jetzt natürlich noch nicht sagen ja
lasst noch nach oben da jetzt glaub ich
werde viel verlieren rucksack mit dem
ich habe drei flaschen die lehrer sind
eingepackt werden also zum beispiel
schon mal 75 cent man kann ja nie wissen
nochmals gebrauchen kann bevor jetzt
losgehen wollte ich noch kurz das sagen
und zwar weiß ich gerade gar nicht haben
wird doch sagen wollte eigentlich sollte
er alle verstanden haben worum es geht
also ich möchte wirklich versuchen
komplett umsonst sachen zu machen und in
den nächsten 24 stunden nicht einen cent
auszugeben weil ich gebe jeden tag schon
jetzt nicht wenig geld aus aber das ist
auch ganz normal wenn man dann plötzlich
alleine lebt und eigentlich für alles
sorgen muss dass das nicht günstig ist
wir schauen noch wo dieses experiment
hinführt und gehen jetzt erst mal in die
city ich hab mir sagen kein plan gemacht
dann würde ich dann erzählen wenn ich
gleich in der stadt bin also losgehen
[Musik]
so wie ich bin natürlich mit der bahn
gefahren und bin jetzt irgendwo dort auf
der anderen rheinseite
mein ziel ist es nämlich einfach im park
zu finden wo ich jetzt flaschen sammeln
kann ist sehr leid
natürlich auch option ein bisschen musik
machen geld sammeln und meinen gitarren
skills und ab geht
ich hasse sage immer wenn leute mich
dabei an kunden gehabt ist mir dass ihr
gehalt war ja leute also wunderschön ich
eigentlich die frage ist jetzt wie komm
ich zumindest ein bisschen gelegt ich
setze mich jetzt erst mal hierhin mal
ein bisschen mit euch weil ich habe eben
schon gesagt ich habe mir so einen
kleinen plan gemacht und mal gucken was
daraus sowie also leute ich hoffe ihr
könnt mich verstehen ich habe jetzt in
meinem rucksack drei flaschen das wären
umgerechnet 75 cent wenn ich die
einlösen und das ist ja wirklich nicht
viel deswegen weiß eigentlich meinen
plan
wir gucken kommen wir nach pfandflaschen
weil wenn man aus 75 cent drei euro
macht es ist ja schon was anderes da
vorne liegt eine weinflasche ich weiß
nur nicht es vermutlich ja vielleicht
zehn cent drauf keine ahnung ich bin
jetzt gerade natürlich mit der bahn
gefahren ich habe ja von meinem
studiengang sondern ein semesterticket
das heißt ich kann immer for free bahn
fahren so viel ich will also auch ganz
cool
ameisen morgen habe ich zwar schon was
gefrühstückt aber ich sollte jetzt will
ich mal zu sehen das war was zum mittag
finden was auch immer keine ahnung
deswegen wenden ist einfach mal die
flaschen gesucht und mal sehen oder das
heute hinführt aber da ist auch nichts
drauf oder leute ich sehe was das hier
gut aus an sich ist ja wirklich scheiße
wenn man seinen müll zurück lässt ich
mache das aber eigentlich nie
heute kann ich wirklich mal sagen dann
kann die leute die hier die coladose
liegen lassen haben kann passt er
perfekt hier nämlich gleich mal mit ein
euro insgesamt
jetzt haben wir schon insgesamt 1 eur 25
mal sehen was noch zu kommen das geht
natürlich bei der ganzen sache nicht
unbedingt nur um essen ja ich versuche
auch vielleicht andere sachen immer
profi zu kriegen nur ich habe keinen
plan was ist in köln so gut ich kann
aber auch so eine wut app da kann man
halt so sachen und seine instagram story
posten und krieg dann ab und zu auch
noch eine flasche und krieg dann ab und
zu etwas umsonst die habe ich noch nie
ausprobiert die würde ich mir gleich mal
runter laden also ein euro 25 ja ich
möchte nicht so 150
mittendrin heute also ein wo sie auf
jeden fall ganz klar sagen
man unterschätzt das so enorm an denkt
über liegen pfandflaschen
aber ich habe jetzt uns gaben 2 euro 25
beim hinten drin
das ist ja noch nicht ich habe auf jeden
fall gerade mann einen supermarkt
besucht er hier in der nähe ist und da
werde ich das jetzt mal einlösen was
zuerst nur weil ich hab echt hunger ist
nun wirklich sehr sehr traurig was die
leute alles liegen lassen so
pfandflaschen eher wenig alles was man
nicht mehr gebrauchen kann oder will man
kein geld mehr kriegt wird liegen
gelassen und ich habe noch was scheiße
ist kein pfand drauf oder also schaut
euch das mal an das sind glaube ich
alles flaschen wo kein pfand drauf ist
oder wenn man kann ich halt wirklich
nicht verstehen wie kann man ja so was
machen meine ich kann mir die situation
aber gut vorstellen hat jemand flaschen
gesammelt und alles was der flaschen
automatisch angenommen so ungefähr 600
meter von hier ist ein supermarkt und
ich würde sagen dahin mache ich mir
jetzt mal auf dem weg zu noch echt am
schwitzen ganz schön waren waren
flaschen sammeln ist anstrengender als
man denkt mal sehen wie viele schritte
ich werde arm gemacht habe das iphone
kann als erzählen und gleichzeitig euch
mal was man alles ich habe es eben
gegoogelt umsonst waren kann ihnen könig
von 75 cent
so leute ab geht's nach hause
jetzt seht euch da immer was ich bin
absolut ko s geschafft
man muss sagen sie halt auch wirklich
ziemlich er sich aus aber ich bin wieder
da leute hier können wir 1 glauben es
war noch nie so anstrengend sich
irgendwas zu essen zu holen wie das hier
bin so froh dass ich wieder hier bin ich
weiß auf jeden fall zwei zweieinhalb
stunden unterwegs mit der bahn gefahren
die auf dem rückweg total überfüllt war
weil hier irgendwie so ein sport event
ist oder so ich bin im supermarkt meinen
pfandflaschen das waren insgesamt zehn
stück mit den dosen oder neue keine
ahnung ich habe auf jeden fall gedacht
das bringt mir zwei jahren 25 hatten wir
am ende dann 1 euro 50 gebracht eine
coladose hat er nicht akzeptiert dann
kann auch irgendwie so eine verkäuferin
die dachte ich glaube was weil ich
meinen rucksack daneben stehen hat dann
muss ich meinen rucksack auskommen das
war total dumm also es war wirklich
extrem stressig habe erst mal wasser
geholt weil ich halt auch durst da habe
ich noch ein paar flip hole ich meine
mehr und aber das bessert habe ich
schnell nicht gefunden und nudeln ihr
fragt euch jetzt sicherlich warum hast
du nicht einfach eine packung nudeln
geholt hätte ich auch machen kann das
war allerdings um zwei goulding und da
gab es nicht viel na ja ich esse jetzt
erstmal irgendwie sehen und gleich
irgendwann später so leute wie jetzt in
die cd auf jeden fall auf jeden fall
habe ich einmal ein subway gutschein
rausgefunden da kriegt man was umsonst
und ich habe außerdem schon von dieser
anderen events
und das war der bahn fast keine autonome
sonst auf jeden fall habe ich mir im
subway coach eingezogen bei bestellung
wenn du jetzt zum beispiel ist also ich
muss jetzt geld das menü weil du hast ja
so kann ich mir auch gleich und sonst
einzubestellen
aber da muss ich eigentlich habe ich
keine lust wird ja dann gehen wir halt
machen der ins tholi ich kann ansonsten
ins tor machen und kann bei vielen
einfach gerade das essen 14
ich weiß nicht ob man das gut sehen kann
aber hier gibt es einiges wie zum
beispiel das chicken teriyaki +1 grad
ist das ist doch lecker oder so wir sind
jetzt in irgend einem parkhaus gelandet
und zwar suchen wir immer noch das
problem und sind jetzt komplett aus ich
war in der innenstadt wollten sind also
da ist dabei aber ich glaube dazu er hat
einfach zu wer macht den 29 uhr zu wo es
müssen wir den ganzen weg bis nach köln
wieder zurück das waren nochmals stunde
bestimmt ja wir haben einen gefunden
halter mit solch schöne stadtrates
zwei hatte bisher ist es im checken
charakter das einzige das
[Musik]
ich bedanke mich so einfach sonst
aufhören sehr gut machst du das ist
einfach schon dunkel und wir sind hier
irgendwo ins nirgendwo gefahren wir
müssen jetzt die bahn wieder nehmen zwei
mal und das dauert aber ich habe jetzt
wirklich noch kein cent bezahlt weil ich
dann morgen
und da hat einen wunderschönen guten
morgen ich bin jetzt schlafen nachdem
gestern waren wir versuchen das
frühstück zu finden ich habe allerdings
vorher ausgelost soweit ich spazieren
irgendeinem schönen waldgebiet und mache
mich auf den weg zu einer kostenlosen
aktivität ich habe das gestern schon mal
raus genug man kann ja einige sachen in
köln umsonst mainz bleibt euch das hier
mal ein ich weiß ja nicht ob ich ganz
wichtig bin ja keine ahnung ob mir das
auch finden werden wir haben hier freier
eintritt zu museen wir haben live musik
ja alles so museums quatsch interessiere
ich mich nicht dafür aber an erster
stelle haben wir hier einen tierpark der
soll wie echt cool sein und dann mache
ich mich jetzt sind und ich hoffe mal
dass wir cool und ich komme sonst rein
was besseres habe ich nicht gefunden
danach geht es dann direkt in die city
war das essen zum frühstück und dann war
es eigentlich auch schon und ich habe
bis jetzt noch kein geld bezahlt so die
frage ist ob ich hier ist einfach
reingehen kann
hier ist auch wirklich eigentlich gar
nichts los
es geht alles fit hier kann man auch die
tiere füttern
ich habe leider kein geld dabei
vielleicht darf nichts ausgeben
mal schauen was das sein es sieht aus
wie ein stein hier könnte man jetzt zum
beispiel futter kaufen
das sind halt wirklich echt richtig
dicke tiere kommen wir ja was zu essen
auch wenn der auf mich zuläuft erinnern
ist aber auch ende interessiert sich gar
nicht für mich so wie ich habe mich
zuerst und für dich na ja jetzt bin ich
auch schon durch das sein steinböcke ja
die kommen aus südafrika über und leben
dann halt hier und spaß ist nur siege
ich bin hier immer noch im tierpark und
ich zeige euch mal die app die ich meine
und zwar nennt sich das irgendwie auch
ich sagte namen gar nicht ist kein
placement hier gibt es auf jeden fall so
leben die nehmen daran teil das ist auf
jeden fall ganz unterschiedlich man kann
sogar burger essen man kann auch wo
ritus essen steht jetzt halt dass man
für eine story post einen 10 euro
gutschein bekommt und ob das wirklich
funktioniert das probieren wir jetzt mal
aus wir fahren in die stadt mit der bahn
und sehen uns einer stunde gefühlt
wieder
bis gleich
diese enthalten
[Musik]
hör einfach den klassiker
im wasser
mir ist schlecht leider war das viel ich
muss wirklich sehr dringend wieder zum
friseur
ich musste einfach kurz die story posten
ich blende das hier mal ein und konnten
für zehn euro ausloben was ich wollte
was ich eigentlich lustig fand das kann
wirklich jeder machen so zum beispiel in
meinem fall wenn ich ein placement
machen würde und das ist meine sorge
packen würde wäre das mehr wert als den
euro war so was ist mir egal es kann
nämlich jeder dahin gehen und zeigen ja
und gerichtskosten meine story in europa
heute also ich habe jetzt wirklich den
letzten 24 stunden komplett nichts
ausgegeben war echt lustig und das ding
ist ja es geht theoretisch ist abgesehen
von der wohnung könne man nicht umsonst
leben da gibt es auf jeden fall ein paar
möglichkeiten das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich selber doch noch umfragen
wir beenden das heißt wir haben ein team
nach 1 und das video soll um 14 online
ich habe den ersten part schon fertig
geschnitten also los geht's sächsischen
rennstall ab und wir sehen uns sondern
wir